beleza gente então pra mim falar de
grafite é eu tenho que fazer uma
retrospectiva e z como é que isso
realmente iniciou na minha vida
ah eu tenho um projeto chamado grafite
arte que transforma isso realmente fez
sentido para mim por isso que é bom
sempre repartida também depois que a
empresa do meu pai ela hoje fale ou
fechou sei lá a gente se mudou para uma
comunidade perto do bairro onde eu
morava
antigamente e comunidade para muitos
fala vila favela fala quebradas e lá
você vai entender e eu estudava numa
escola chamada fundação bradesco e me
formei lá e continuo estudando lá mesmo
tenha me mudando para essa comunidade
tinha uma certa distância e mesmo que
fosse pouca a gente eu e os meus irmãos
a gente se formou nesta instituição e
desde pequena sempre desenhava sempre
fazer rabiscos sempre gostava de desenho
e foi justamente nessa escola que eu
tive a oportunidade de realmente ver o
quão longe a arte pode aquela pessoa e
ele só eu tinha 9 anos
na minha escola tinha um concurso de
desenho que se você ganhasse esse
concurso seu desenho virava capa em
todas as instituições
então amanhã seu desenho estampado em
todos os cadernos em todas as escolas
por era o máximo para poder rodar assim
cara foi o que fiz
e aí todo mundo ri e com para gostar
junto e também festeja com você e essa
minha professora era sirlei nome dela
esperam taxa errando aqui mas ela vai
lembrar qualquer coisa me escreve depois
ela me ajudou muito ela dava 3ª série e
você tinha sintomas da matéria no
professor só então era meu era muito
massa e se ela me auxiliou muito me
ajudou bastante a desenvolver sua arte
para poder participar desse concurso e o
grande prémio deste concurso era um
estojo aquele cheio de canetinha lápis
régua estou assim que se olha na vitrina
sinpoci a mãe queria um desse mas ela
não podia comprar pra mim então é um
baita uma baita realização poder um
estojo tem um estojo de se esses amigos
rodrigo e grega ea gente sempre desejou
junto sempre trabalhou juntos em meus
parceiros
eu gosto muito desses caras então todas
as idéias que vinham a gente desejava
cada um fazer uma leitura de alguma
coisa e isso contribui muito do meu
crescimento como artista
então nessa quebrada onde morava nessa
vila em gravataí
não sei se você conhece o grande do sul
região metropolitana de porto alegre é a
quarta pior cidade do estado ea onde eu
morava também não era muito legal era
bem problemático e eu cresci nesse
ambiente e esse ambiente era muito
monocromático e nesses nesse lugar ali
shimo ginásio que as pessoas vão se nos
ensinavam a perspectiva de vida ser
pessoas melhores
o agente skate tinha basquete vôlei e
tudo que a gente fazia ali dentro desse
cenário as pessoas doavam do seu tempo
para connosco para nos ensinar realmente
que onde você mora não determina quem
você é
essa foi é ou quando eu ouvi isso visto
desse cara e vou levar isso comigo e eu
comecei fazendo estêncil na verdade foi
um rapaz chamado ariel ele estava
fazendo uns rabiscos no ginásio mas
letras e me interessei por aqui o mano
que está fazendo ponto fazendo grafite
seguinte letra que o euro está eu tal me
mostrou e foi a minha primeira interação
com grafite foi aí só que tem um pequeno
porém se eu saísse rabiscando o daniel
morava existiam dana minha mãe tinha
vários tipos de havaianas
então cada um tipo de dano sempre
entendi que eu queria dizer então era
melhor que não fizesse fizesse algo
diferente e eu comecei a fazer
existência
só que naquela época a gente não tinha
muito acesso à internet uma chamada tem
mudanças em que vocês sabem modem
tipinho pai a internet é uma maravilha
se reclama na internet hoje mano nunca
passou por aqui então eu comecei a
pesquisar e achei uma artista bem se eu
achei demais artes dele e comecei a
reproduzir isso dentro da minha
comunidade porque não tinha nada de bom
a ela tudo parede lisa tijolo à vista da
casa caindo pra tentar alegrar o
ambiente eu sair pela rua pedindo
autorização mas sem fazer figura de
desenhos de figuras cultura pop e blues
dog blues brothers escola de rock minhas
formas de existência e foi aí que
comecei a me interessar bastante pelo
que já fiz tanto que um dia eu
substituir as próprias
outras do ariel nesse ginásio ayrton e
eu fazendo os rabiscos
só que grafite nunca foi só a mostrar
arte ou a que legal você faz um trabalho
de maneira sempre tem algo por trás a
responsabilidade de transmitir a coisa
certa
foi aqui um dia eu entendi que grafite
realmente é a palavra é a arte daquele
que não fala é a expressão que você quer
mostrar o que tem acontecido ou seja na
minha comunidade
toda vez que a polícia chegava ou beleza
vai levar o transporte embora não eles
iam pegar propina conhecem minha vida
inteira até o sair de lá e sempre foi
e essa arte que eu fiz foi inspirado
benxi ea leitura dela pra mim era é o
seguinte a inocência de uma criança
fazendo uma dando uma batida num
policial é o seguinte
toda vez que a polícia entrava lá
levando meu sonho porque eles não me
protegendo eles não estão fazendo seu
serviço eles estão levando talvez dois
anos da minha vida ou pode ser
atropelado uma bala perdida alguma coisa
acontecer comigo então eles estão
levando só então não sei se depreciou o
que está levando ainda a minha vida hoje
então é incrível é você fazer uma
leitura realmente perguntar por artista
o que ele pensou em fazer isso foi a
primeira vez que eu vi a
responsabilidade de transmitir a arte na
parede
desde então uma professora lá em 2009 me
chamou pra poder dar aula em escola
pública e se na grafite lá tem um turno
integral o universo pra quem conhece
isso aí e ela me chamou assim você pode
ensinar às crianças pode mostrar como é
que você faz essas artes e tal eu beleza
vamos lá essa escola na minha com
própria comunidade só que eu concordei
com a ideia sem saber a gravidade disso
porque a gravidade em parte da nossa
vida a gente é transmissor e receptor
imagina você passar as ideias erradas
passar os propósitos errados vai se
replicar coisas erradas e assim vai ser
continuamente
então ouvi meu deus eu sei tem uma uma
proposta que eu nem medir o tamanho e aí
acabou que eu estudei mais ainda sobre
grafite me interessei mais sobre grafite
para mostrar aquelas crianças que
grafite não é só o rabisco ao muro não é
só pegar o malote
spray e passei dois anos ensinando em
duas escolas da do 3º ano a o segundo
ano mais ou menos
foi muito bom esse tempo lá em 2002
cheguei em rio do sul chega logo depois
da enchente 2011 enchente
aí pessoal tava se juntando ainda
arrumando as suas casas
eu cheguei aqui comecei a fazer rabiscos
ele ache bica ea pesada que estava
sempre disse o que está fazendo aí manpo
eu lembrei dorielton fazendo grafite
mann fazendo o efeito fazendo é dando
mais ajeitada na casa aqui e eu lembro
que morava perto da unidade
eu fiz um grafite bem legal uma casa
depois da enchente ela ficou assim mas
estava toda suja de barro e eu vou
colocar esse lugar porque pode ter algo
de bonito a ideia foi lá e fiz um
trabalho naquela garagem durar um tempo
também até reformarem
e aí eu comecei da a uma escola que o
pessoal me chamou para poder ensinar pra
galera entre workshops fazer trabalho de
médio e curto prazo eu comecei a escolas
fazendo o mesmo trabalho já fazendo rio
grande do sul fazendo aqui em santa
catarina aí tem alguns exemplos de
trabalhos de ensinar e mostrar porque
uma grande com um gol de fato
interessante é o seguinte estava na
unidade uma vez fazer um workshop de
grafite ea gente sabe que às vezes o que
as pessoas nos dizem ficar gravado na
nossa mente é uma das meninas perguntou
por que a associação é porque todo
grafiteiro é o usuário mas é as pessoas
associam por isso tudo você faz um
rótulo porque meu pai me disse minha mãe
diz que é assim então você cresce
pensando a mesma coisa daí cidade
pequena e tal não que isso faça sentido
aí eu disse o seguinte não sei quando
você conhece mas eu não
talvez isso mudou a percepção dela sobre
grafite sobre a pista mudou talvez
aqueles aquela fração de segundo ela
pôde ver de uma forma diferente e alguns
trabalhos que eu fiz com o pessoal das
escolas mostrando a arte deles com a
minha
isso foi crescendo ao longo do tempo a
responsabilidade de ensinar sem foi uma
coisa que eu precisei muito para dizer
que as coisas não são como eles dizem os
meus pais me disseram meus amigos
disseram mas sim achar alguém te deu a
informação certa que passa a informação
certa e interagir com a arte é muito
legal não tem alguns exemplos de
crianças escolas
pintar em um ônibus com a gurizada é foi
incrível e dentro disso a pessoa começar
a acreditar mais no meu trabalho começar
a acreditar em mim
tanto que investiram para mim poder
fazer trabalhos bem distante
temos aqui é uma pista no paraná tem
aqui um lugar em lisboa portugal
temos estados unidos e trabalhos que a
gente tem feito no recife também em
comunidades de restaurar pintar trazer
alegrias pra cima pra comunidade assim
como foi pra mim é tão bem legal a minha
esposa meu braço direito ela sempre teve
então na verdade é que eu tô bonita a
akihito foi lá o protagonismo é melhor
estações de tinta pra mim e alguns
trabalhos que eu fiz ao longo da cidade
por aí afora do sul e outros municípios
mas beleza falar de grafite
mas por que fazer grafite é um grande
exemplo isso aqui vocês estão vendo é
uma na indonésia eo esgotamento essa
foto de impacto isto é um trabalho meu
mas é pra mim e dizer pra você o com
importante o grafite também na vida das
pessoas
a relação de uma comunidade destruída
onde as pessoas não têm perspectiva de
vida que está esperando só pelo leito da
morte mesmo que vai ser assim poeta da
vida acabou
mas imagina colorir esse lugar foi o que
fizeram
colorir todo esse lugar que isso mudou
na vida das pessoas não foi que o
grafite realmente ó transformou do dia
pra noite eu digo que elas passaram a
enxergar em cores elas eram
monocromáticas e passar a enxergar em
cores que isso refletiu na vida delas
autoestima zelo pela sua comunidade
mudou o relacionamento dela com as
pessoas de fora viram um ponto turístico
eles mesmo fazem a manutenção desse
lugar porque eles tomaram para si essa é
a minha cidade é o meu bairro eu quero
que as pessoas possam sair daqui felizes
ou infelizes antes agora se ofereça não
porque o grafite transformou em si mas
porque eu pude enxergar em cores
alguns outros trabalhos realizados pela
cidade também compartilhando você se
grafite é bem diversa mas e aí essa
história interessante quem é de rio do
oeste aí é um trabalho que eu fiz em
lindoeste uma vez
a esse senhor zinho ali é o ele é o
pessoal que coordena a questão das obras
lá é muito engraçado ele quanto eu fiz
esse desenho ele meio que de um bug na
cabeça dele e de cara como é que você
fez isso depois de chute não falar eu
vou tirar uma foto e conselheira foto
decidiu de com um bom é poder ver e
ouvir alguém realmente mudar assim pra
você e dizer que legal estão interagindo
parte mas nunca pensei que isso fosse
possível e é muito legal
outros trabalhos que realizei por aí
também afora esse aqui é de rio do sul
já conhece é uma longa história esse
trabalho porque porque esse trabalho
assim poderia fazer qualquer coisa mas
eu pensei diferente vou fazer algo para
a cidade
a cidade abraçou eu preciso abraçar essa
cidade como minha também
então decidi fazer um cartão postal para
a cidade porque assim quando as pessoas
valorizam um lugar tipo tudo muda
eu valorizei como artista um lugar onde
estava rabiscado não tinha nada e as
pessoas começaram a gostar disso o
grafite ele precisa ter uma linguagem
bem claro as pessoas precisam entender o
que está sendo passado na mensagem desse
tipo
agora entendi não porque tem as letras
web está em outros estilos que lhes dá
um problema realmente na leitura mas
quando as olha assim elas pegam pra ser
tipo é o grafite da minha cidade eu vou
manter isso aqui limpo porque isso mudou
o meu dia talvez a pessoa está passando
meio cabisbaixo ele por baixo do viaduto
olha assim embate legal
já pra frente ela já não vai esquecer
todo o problema dela de sair de casa
chutou cachorro brigou com a mulher não
sei se ela voltar vai querer consertar
isso
o poder da arte é exatamente esse isso
aqui vocês viram né
durante o evento que estava aqui eu
estava fazendo isso no meio pintado
ainda mas é mais beleza chegando a mão e
falamos sobre grafite falamos sobre tudo
isso
mas o que isso realmente tem influência
na tua vida eu digo tudo
não vou dizer sim grafite me salvou mas
literalmente isso me ajudou a tornar uma
pessoa melhor porque entende que a
responsabilidade como ser humano
do lado do seu tempo também não é só
receber receber receber alguém me dê um
dia eu preciso dar isso para alguém ou
para algumas pessoas é exatamente uma
forma que eu carrego comigo não é
matemática porque isso aqui tem que ser
vivida oportunidade mais relacionamento
igual influência é simples não é simples
é cada dia oportunidade de poder estar
com vocês oportunidade de partilhar com
vocês minhas idéias gerando um
relacionamento de alguém vai ser daqui
pensando por legal grafite não é aquilo
que a minha mãe me disse o que ouvi os
gritos fazendo no muro pode ser muito
mais pode mudar o dia-a-dia de alguém
pode transformar um lugar como aconteceu
ante a islândia e as pessoas têm
perspectiva de vida assim como eu tive
eu saí da minha comunidade
lá realmente poderia ter outro outro
futuro poderia ter tido se eu tivesse
aceitado que é aquela realidade mas não
o grafite e transformou e é isso que eu
tenho feito oportunidade relacionamento
igual influência dinheiro disse
não é todo homem que dá o que não pode
reter para ganhar o que não pode perder
é simplesmente deixe fluir através de
minhas idéias meu ensino as coisas que
eu tenho feito não só pra mim pra todo
mundo
o grafite é a galeria da rua e
transmitir minhas idéias para que
pessoas possam ter realmente uma visão
melhor da sua comunidade do seu lugar e
onde elas se encontram e isso é minha
vida essas são as minhas ferramentas
tipo faça o melhor possível dentro do
tempo que foi dado porque no final das
sessões que fica essas são as minhas
ferramentas
eu não sei quais são as suas obrigado
[Aplausos]